nice today we're with producer grant
rody AK and we're gonna be playing Sims
4 and we're very excited
I've never played The Sims before but
this is Beth's favorite game of all time
yeah any game this is all she plays and
I think it's because Beth likes to
control other people this is maybe yes I
think this is we're going deep in Beth's
emotional psyche today I grant it was
nice enough to make a special game with
a couple people in it with us and Conan
and all this stuff so I think in the
beginning we're gonna start by making
our own character because I want to make
somebody totally crazy and then we'll go
into what you guys have made for us you
can see in the bottom corner
it's pretty awesome alright so can you
just so this is just a guy you randomly
make yes you can you can choose the
gender first you can change the name you
can even randomize between options to
sort of see things you like so if you
like that I know that guy that's my
friend Dave guys that's crazy
don't change that facial hair but
changed everything about us about this
person exactly Oh Gabrus says I put way
too many hours in this Sims 3 what are
some of the exciting things about about
Sims more in the new expansion you think
about the sims 4 it's really fun even
just starting right here and create a
sim is that one thing we did with the UI
is instead of having a bunch of buttons
and menus let's ripple oh dude this is
crazy you can ask that guy's body is
very weird yet familiar to me so you can
grab any part of their body and just
manipulate it directly and then you
could sit there and you can say well
let's make this guy super ripped whoa
but he's still got a weird beard asleep
I love this so you can sit there and
stretches stomach out or you could
stretch his butt out when we're doing
early testing on this the number one
thing people did at the start was to
grab women's breasts Oh shocking shocker
so you could sit there and you can
basically create anyone you want you can
name them I had I love really funny
random names the other day I had a
synonym Lillet Clement who lilyc and I
really well I mean her husband Nate was
Grosso his little claim it's gross I
love this guy he carries his weight in
his stomach his face is still thin he
just goes out here and you can pick any
outfit you want so like you could pick
this soccer jersey here or Brandis says
hot I think we're learning a lot about
you Brandis what you like you can choose
from pre-made look so sweatpants here I
feel like this could be just its own
game this is why even do anything else
this get Sims five it's just the
character cream when we released the
demo which is free right now in origin
just the criticism demo you we had
people spend like 500 600 hours in the
sea Jesus seriously pick mustaches you
can make the mustache blue you can make
the mustache pink you could say match my
hair so you don't have to remember what
it was
let's do like the let's go up a little
bit with the hair oh yeah let's oh
that's yeah let's do big beard biblical
beer a terrific tile of it we can kind
of like it this is sparta kind of said
you change all sorts of hair we can give
them sort of this stylish Oh death night
remembers Beth when he said with your
favorite thing to do in the Sims was put
everybody in a pool and take the ladders
away Beth is this your killer you're
what we call the deviant player
development damned those thighs yeah
dude junk junk junk in the trunk looking
good Jesus oh you know pick the socks
wants to see us make dr. Phil let's make
a dr. Phil this character well so first
thing dr. Phil a friend of the show and
we're going to make him and embarrass
him in The Sims it's give us a calmness
so dr. Phil is bald who retrospective
live has already played The Sims 4 446
what it was at four thousand six hundred
and seventy seven hours he's got a
mustache no beard oh so far you and it's
not blue this is this gonna I can you go
a thicker mustache
oh let's see if we got one but you know
what this is good but let's just go
eyebrows black if let's fix those
I'm dr. house your dr. Phil impression
these days well you see I gotta get that
sounds like I've overheard more water
what are you gonna wear a suit uh yeah
let's go like first doctor doc Dart
yeah we should we should prefix the skin
tone a little bit yeah there we go
ah maybe a little darker well swarthy er
there we go yeah that looks a little dr.
village and then I feel like he's got
like kind of a big he's kind of just a
big dude like it's not like he's fat but
he's kind of like his shoulders are
large so buddy siddharth builder okay
whoa there we go Darth Vader
doctor fellow Phil out on the town yeah
okay
yeah oh you know what this looks like
this looks like kind of cash dr. Phil
yeah leisure shoes leisure Phil
something yeah uh something maybe shot a
little little dressy little bling some
boots yeah let's do it let's do it then
all that we could do these and he's got
that Texas swagger yeah that's right
va claims exactly dr. Vader sure we
haven't dr. Phil is not ripped
Wow jock have you seen dr. Phil no
disrespect to dr. Phil they think he
works out his mind or his mouth more
than his muscles yeah that's good I
think you want it you want to kind of
pick up this cockiness yeah it's a skyyy
it's kind of like a robust so where's
dr. Phil after what's his aspiration
accomplished so money that's money
that's what I thought fabulously
fabulously well so what is personnel so
we have lots of different traits and
this determines how he thinks oh this is
great okay cool wow really
is he a genius is he a hothead so sure
creative self-assured for sure yeah quit
self-assurance foodie art lover bookworm
we've got glutton snob meat
I do get the idea that he's kind of
snobby he's kind of he's better than
other people right but yeah yeah
family-oriented mean outgoing
jealousy here's the thing no stop your
little bro we're really getting into my
feelings about dr. Phil which is I think
it's he's not 100% honest with how he
portrays himself now this might be I
don't want to go off a second here
yeah but you know what I'm saying like I
think he portrays himself as this guy or
Walker about her but really in real life
he's kind of you know don't you think
ambitious ambitious yes how about money
and Chris Lehane could be insane insane
Oh what do you think that we can get rid
of one of these others we've got only
room for three though damn okay
this all seems this all seems good okay
just like super overconfident
is there like nosey or like like in
another body and everybody's business
like gossip you
there's outgoing okay outgoing yeah yeah
that's oh wait what's that what's that
what do we have in Z cloning down Oh
childish lazy oh I don't want to offend
dr. Phil I know he watches this is one
of things is you can't be with be a snob
and a child assembly okay fair enough
okay I'm yet let's say family orient all
right all right you know so so we can
change his outfits for lots of different
style oh my god formal Phil of course
party Phil we're really changing my
thoughts about dr. Phil he's swimwear
exactly yeah and we already said this
clip is gonna be shown the next time
he's on Cody oh my god
bobafet terrifying hot dog on the client
Oh perfect ahh let's just go straight up
Phil let's go straight up Phil so stick
back to this yeah stick back cuz I feel
like you get too far away from Phil it's
not the heart of what actually Phil is
okay this is great I'm jumping in the
game are you don't look at the other
people well let's jump never got Conan
perfect perfect there's uh there wait is
it not Andy it is Andy oh wow looking
good now this show this yeah Andy never
dresses that nice ever we can you we
always wear shorts no no we'll leave all
right Andy looks great there there's
Beth Oh fat masturbating Barry looks
great there's you I got lost in here I
love it he's a good cut of an Asian
marketing team got a chick and then of
course dr. Phil
perfect we ready to go we're ready to go
let's get in here let me see this
hipster fill hipster fill somebody say
that's right so we have set you up with
this enormous house that is basically
full of all sorts of stuff from the base
game from the expansion's we wanted to
give you a fun house with a lot of cool
things to do all of it we don't want you
have to build it up and wait and this is
gonna be extremely dumb for you no no
but for people who don't know we've
never played The Sims explain what this
game is so the Sims is it's a life
simulator it is all about telling
stories and trying to create the things
you wanna create whether it's creating
your Sims or creating your own home you
can guess the White House you'd make it
the full house your twin sister you can
live the life you've always wanted and
then / never dared to dream yeah you can
have those like fantasies that you have
like she's like I want to kill everyone
I work that is a lot of or you know we
can have like random love stories you
could sort of you can make someone that
looks just like your girlfriend and then
you can make some that looks just like
you and then you can have them breed and
you can see what your weird digital
Children was amazing you can effectively
do amazing whatever you can imagine so
what you're saying is I don't need to
feel bad about the fact that I can't get
a date I could just do this have a date
oh my god
simulate what it would be like and we
simulate me not dating in this game oh
hey Sohail Ahmed from India good to see
you thanks for joining us what time is
it in India by the way either really
later really early that's crazy
but he or says we finally get to see
Conan's home life this is exactly his
home
exactly grant we let grant into Conan's
house and he mapped the whole thing it's
that's really nice Oh crazy well good
thing we're on YouTube also YouTube
you're winning you're winning which is
glitchy I love it
alright here we go alright so what do
you want to do here I've set up all
sorts of relationships I have lots of
objects so we've got the pool we've got
a hot tub
let's get you know what let's get Conan
inside and let's let's have Conan wander
around the house a little bit right look
at this swank pad literally is the size
TV in this house a whole movie theater
and we could see what dr. Phil does on
so we tried to create a home
and I love [ __ ] walks like oh we gave
him the goofball walks and forgot to
show you is that I'm gonna watch Sims of
the Dead with Ernesto and you and I'll
come in and watch man you guys made me
so handsome thank you I appreciate her a
really good-looking guy it was hard to
find the Sims were trying to make you to
uh clearly don't have a a turd between
two shoulders setting which is good is
there bread in the game is there bread
in this game we have a no-carb no so
yeah we have tons of red we have loves a
nice piece of it so we've created the
whole monster movie here for your sims
to watch and it's got all sorts of plot
and so the burner will come in and watch
and the sims a bit scared why is this
very chatting me up here this is
ridiculous
by the way that is my I'm just always
like let's have her come over here and
play
you wanna play don't play foosball with
her yeah let's do it alright so you
can't get them out of the way but here's
the thing I don't let girls win man even
if I like them I go hard and I go Sims
don't have any notion of chivalry
alright good cuz neither did neither
does neither this real-life player so we
can sit here and watch this whole movie
and what you notice here is that they
all have different emotional states
right now so this is one of the other
new things we put in the game is that we
wanted what do you mean how do we know
what the emotional state so you look
down here in the bottom left corner my
sim right now is focused which makes him
a bit of a nerd if a Conan is happy oh
cool Sims can be sad they can be angry
they can be so hysterical that they can
die if you tell them another joke they
could be so angry they die from rage you
can kill someone by telling them jokes
Wow just like Conan's monologue I'm sold
pickles that we're trying to move up
Maslow's hierarchy of needs which is a
really nerdy way to say we don't want
our sim to be obsessed with just peeing
your the game is all about I'm hungry I
got ready you're gonna sleep so we went
our sims to have sort of deeper
emotional worries now the hierarchy of
needs is basically what shelters it's
like shelters like that's like here Eve
man yeah and we're trying to get up here
to swim down here everything's good
we've got food we have to worry about
food then then what's the second one
then what don't eat all right polythene
once we go past ping then what Cheetos
kudos she's book good book then at the
top is like log or something well it's
probably emotional satisfaction
satisfaction what think you know climb
in that pyramid oh yeah
don't aim to be all about nurturing
their behavior instead of you know just
keeping them alive because right frankly
I hope at least from me and you know
know about Beth but because staying
alive isn't so difficult so we can come
up here and we can do like commando job
dude let's do it
Conan in the mirror because he likes to
focus on himself
Oh Brandis says food is at the bottom
yeah I think it right I think it's food
then shelter but get us the hierarchy of
needs here Google the house stop staring
at this I know you're in love with this
game it's it's food shelter then like
like sexy sexy explodes like looking
good we gave her the tattoo [ __ ] stamp
just like real life
oh we can do that we wanted to treat him
respectfully as the famous star this is
this is PC right this is PC I was a PC
game the PC gives us all sorts of crazy
flexibility like for example we have
this whole huge community where you can
download thousands of different sims and
house and all sorts of things that
people create oh my god
so if I create a sim I can upload it for
other people yeah that's awesome we
could upload this cone in fact we can
probably all sorts of Conan's right now
and see what other people think like it
is scary might get a little lazy Kony's
how you doing down here playing foosball
so this foosball just came out in the
recent expansion we just made called
get-together which is all about friends
hanging out and partying and such le
parc says pyramid okay here we go needs
basic needs like food and shelter then
safety that's something in the middle in
the top is self-actualization whoa
that's deep it's real deep little deep
oh this is great so that's good Oh am i
kicking her ass I want to be able to
just you can see cuz you'll have a mood
little spins though no no no 360 spins
that's why we're making a frenzy I don't
want to put it out no no no 360 spins we
don't oh man she's terrible at defense
I'm kicking her ass this is awesome oh
man I'm more about winning than
friendship is that part of my
personality in here well so one of
things you can do is you have social
interactions so you could be nice and
you could write in her day or you can
brighten her day let's pray let's start
Eunice whereas those
wings I feel like she's getting feeling
a little self-conscious let's cancel
this interaction Titans $99.99 wants to
know are there any deaths in this game
there are a lot of different deaths a
lot of different we are sort of obsessed
with death death is a part of life
they're sort of a really funny but you
guys you and Beth you should go work for
them so for example if we go down in
this basement hint that things so cool
and if they run out of energy if they
get too exhausted they could drown that
loves that if you lock them behind these
doors and you don't feed them they'll
die by starvation this is so die of old
age one of our favorite ways to die of
old age is if you get too old if you get
you all what do you maybe get to so soon
start out as babies they become children
teens young adults adults what what
elders what's like this span of time of
real life time that we're talking is it
like one to ten or something so an hour
in the game is a minute got it okay so a
full day if you're not changing the
speed at all roughly twenty four minutes
but you can change time and you go
faster or slower wait so that person who
is playing for 4000 second or 77 hours
has lived like a hundred Beca hundred
years in lives
that's just like in third third in the
future now I suddenly raves upon graves
of hungry Sims can come back as ghosts
oh my god that's really that's grim so
yeah so you you could die of old age um
there's a two-word elders have a chance
of dying during woohoo
oh they leave a night they live 90 days
if I recall correctly if somebody says
well it's actually it's tunable so the
thing is there's there's um which is a
game designer it speak for that once
you're an elder you're gonna live a
minimum number of days and then there's
a dice roll that happens every day which
is a bit dark which determines how long
you live so you could live just like
real life gray I know I stroll so click
that's a mate a dice roll every day to
see whether you're gonna live today or
not
oh my god that's awesome also with this
for example Conan up here where do you
go where's gonna see I'll be nuts
Conan's really confident I'm a good
workout dr. Phil dr. up you know what it
is true to life that's what he does
so that's really disgusting WWB gets so
upset when Conan just goes to the
bathroom and so the bear so the bear
right now is all focused and feeling
nerdy so he wants to go this way let's
see what the Bears gonna go do he's
gonna go do the observatory so you can
also die by anger as I said you could
die by the embarrass my god the bear is
a pervert he's trying to look at people
undressing it's a really high-powered
microscope so yeah we have tons of death
blazing de-ager this game is out now yes
this game being released my wife needs
us also blaze I don't mean to say
anything bad but maybe you should also
play this game with your wife instead of
letting her create a reality that you're
not providing I'm just one of them you
want to be careful that you don't have
men on your sims family and he had
something really terrible be careful
yeah just just all I'm saying is maybe
you should play it together that's
always there was a really great reddit
thread world guy was talking about how
his roommate came in and found his like
and his roommate was like why do you
have a murder dungeon he's like don't
worry about it
this bear is Indic wit man he's jogging
all around you know I played the
masturbating bear on tour and I worked
out in that suit so it smells like
garbage I mean it smelled like vomit
before now it smells like me which is
terrible Hey look it let's follow beth
around for a while
I'm just enjoying fire you're just
hanging out oh she's really gonna pee
you are a murderer who likes fire
dressed in a hot dog suit this game is a
little so wait Titans asking this is
actually your question
Kent do your characters as they age look
older yes they'll get wrinkles they'll
get gray hair going modify them so that
they don't look so oh my god oh
Conan's walking on name now cut all
right let's play video games this this
is what's great here is that I didn't I
didn't oh so he's doing uh where does he
go he's free for oh he jumped in so what
happened is he went to the pool and his
clothes fell off and he's just like oh
yeah fell off in quotes actually the
Sims one that's great oh my god that's
actually bit so what's funny here this
this shows off the
I didn't cheat any of this I just sis's
all yeah this is not scripted I didn't
know that Conan was gonna get naked
there I was playing it last week to test
Conan never got naked now these two are
like well now she's gotta pee no just
Conan's did you work oh my god Beth
since we work for Conan we're trying to
protect him and yesterday I was playing
all that work because I made the bear
mean with everyone so Conan character on
point if you look down here in the
corner you could see the relationships
that they everybody and like the bear
hates you
yes Andy yeah and so the bear also has
an awkward thing with Conan where he is
hot and cold where they both hate each
other but they're lovers
let's go I wanna go see Conan again I
want to make sure he's not doing the
turn he probably is probably is he's
coding
swagger he's just naked playing so the
thing is is your Sims have needs where
they they have to select they have to
eat they have to pee they have to have
social interaction they have fun and so
right now he's like I need to have fun
and so now he needs social interactions
oh he's gonna go kiss Beth oh yes again
I'm not doing anything or just letting
Conan just words if that bear hates dr.
dines ask this would be great in VR have
you guys thought about a VR Sims you
Mustard's uh everybody's course of
thought about it it's my I'm like wow
this is Beth sausage nightmare let's go
skinny-dipping like the hot tub this is
crazy the coning in real life does not
have a tattoo in his heart but also he
doesn't walk around naked so it's a
little a little different some some
we can have the bear come over here and
practice on the DJ booth I will see the
bears very sad so there's one of my
favorite things is that when you have
the bear normally the Sims based on
their emotions will change their
portrait to reflect that okay it's like
oh yeah oh yeah and you're happy okay
well what's Andy doing right now where
is he he's probably got a pee he's over
here playing horseshoes
apparently until he pees his pants this
is play fun stuff we Cohen's fantasy
kiss Beth naked if we wanted we could
just we could let Andy go pee on his own
or we can let him suffer we can lock him
in the dungeon and see what happens no
no no no let's just let him go people
cool I'm afraid of Andes
so we're gonna go pee so you can see
their different emotions what I love
about the bear is that because it's a
full body asset
he just looks lifeless because he has
those cold dead bear right Oh see now
he's all sad sad so let's see here it
says that the bear he has a doomed
relationships oh oh oh so the bear had a
relationship I set up a relationship
with a hot dog okay when you cone and
kiss her please her name is Beth not
just a hot there's a person so respect
the bear is jealous oh look everybody's
coming here and peeing on the bushes
something I have stinkfly's oh the bear
is jealous that Beth his beloved hot dog
was with somebody else so now it's a
doom relationship so he's gonna go over
Pratt he's gonna go through DJ what I
also love the Sims have different
outputs based on their their moods and
their emotions so if you're an artist
and you said he's just laying magnetic
sad little things just playing terrible
magnetic fields he's like no one dances
so this is great cause you can hear him
a terrible teacher he has no skills and
so it's totally derpy I love it but he's
gonna get better over time get a shoe
made in The Sims 4 quit going overseas
go virtual it's a great idea the hot dog
has a name so I can I can challenge her
to a dance battle for example let's just
really rub this in I'm feeling playful
so wait so somebody s and I'm guessing
they're aether is there an online
multiplayer feature um so there's not
online multiplayer this is a
single-player game this is a game oh
about I don't wall
I don't want when I make my world I
don't want Beth coming in with their
dirty hotdog suit and ruining my game
however we have this awesome
rich vibrant community that they create
these things called legacy challenges
where they'll do things like let's see
who can get to the top level of this
career with only one city get some
cereal of course mom's probably hungry
right now oh my God he's like later some
over here dancing now what is it wait
what's quota
what's naked Conan doing he's in this
Masseria
you know dude what whoa what is your
problem put on some clothes I see here
he's got the free-flying from jumping
into our own clothes come he's like oh
dude my seat suit just come off you're
welcome
so in the middle of like totally messing
around and doing all this stuff you get
over there you see my sweet moves
is that your sins can get jobs do you
brought props headed dance that's maybe
not fair
whoa oh great dancer I know wait what it
what is this so what is she saying here
what is going so the fun thing with the
Sims they don't speak English right he
speak a gibberish they speak emoticons
image and they have emoticons and like
the we're all by the way going to spit
it's where we're going yeah yeah and so
you can interrupt so she's like aw man
I'm feeling the music this is really my
jam I had this screenshot once of a sim
looking up in this corner and his face
was looking way up and he was thinking
rat really that must be a huge rat hey
where's the huge rat coming from there's
no rats in the world
see I think Conan finally put his
clothes on some goofy
can I put clip for God's sake let's see
am i eating I'm not eating okay grilled
cheese seems love cheese this is a
famous man this is a fantasy for me
because I don't eat carbs anymore so
this is amazing I love this game already
and so that's the idea is you can just
watch your Sims and see what the heck
they're gonna do everything is naked but
on that food thingy now did you know you
can also build things you can build your
house you can buy new objects you can
spend the money well really let's place
all right let's check out our house a
little bit well well actually can be
what do you wanna do let's actually look
at the house I haven't looked see right
so let's take a quick tour so I'm
thinking are you guys gonna add pets to
sims 4 um you know maybe that's always
been a very popular thing for our fans
and everybody loves dogs but right now
it's not what about can you what about
if you only add monkeys as pets so it
you could just have a hundred monkeys a
house a month I would like that well
that's my pitch tea and they just come
over he's sim with the only fling poo
they would only as well yeah they'd only
fling poo I think but you could dress
them up in little tuxedos you don't have
to say like does
in checks in kind of like oh wait so
this is our island so what this is your
island I'm zooming out so this is the
world of windin berg who just came out
with you together this is sort of a
European themed world's got a little bit
of Cohen Germany look at them look like
in the corner squad goals yeah this is a
postcard goes right here so you can see
that we've done two state there's a
hedge maze or your haunted castle OB oh
my god it's like The Shining you've got
the ruins you've gotten like nightclubs
and stuff like that and we actually have
multiple different worlds that you can
go look at the desert we've guys free
worlds that we gave out to people
Magnolia you know Willow Creek which is
sort of like your your sort of New
Orleans so let's go back here this is
great
so we've lots of different places I want
to give you that top-down view so we're
gonna go back to our house wait a second
back up a second so if I get this world
do these things come in it or I have to
make these things in this world this is
if this all comes with it this comes
here then you could do whatever you want
once you're there God so we did give our
players for free one huge world that
just has 15 blank Lots they could do
whatever they want to normally we ship
it with your nightclubs venues like lo
dice pool the dance club the library oh
my god awesome and our Sims could go
anywhere in this world and go anywhere
so here's our lot this is one of the
biggest slots in the game and it's sort
of so we've got a rocket launcher of
course sure um the Observatory over here
in the woods we've got some outdoor with
the bonfire the own it's getting dark
shoes dark it's a full night day cycle
wait so what are our what are some is
doing right now they are they just
chilling well at some point they're I
don't go to sleep but dr. Phil's feeling
pretty confident right now why he's just
self-assured
you can't actually take a confident poop
and you can take an angry poop we try to
just just like I don't know what a
confident poop I put that I think you do
so in the backyard overshare we've got
the massage table we've got the hot tub
we've got the pool so over here we have
our nice little kitchen where you can
cook all to different recipes and you
can learn new recipes as you go you do a
celestial Seasonings tea situation going
on here look at all these teas we got
sort of at Yvonne oh my god look at this
nice little smokey of teas looks like
Conan's evil whoa great Father's so
you've got the kitchen here where your
Sims are gonna eat you've got the living
room where Conan is going to watch job
now then we want to take it
this is exactly coated this is great so
we've got the arcade machine you got
musical instruments your students can
learn to jam guitar they can play violin
they can play ya know someone's asking
now can we have dr. Phil give Conan a
massage yes you said it's such a grim
way well it's not a tough thing so I can
offer massage give a Swedish massage
because I don't know many massages but
if dr. Phil had more Skills sure there's
lots of different massages he would be
able to do so let's go watch him does
this work on Mac it does actually does
work on Mac it you there's one version
of the game and it works on Mac or PC oh
how many dlcs you guys have planned so
we already have on this we've got two
expansion packs right you've got get
together we've got get to work expansion
so you can own your own business you can
be a scientist or a detective get
together and I'd be a scientist
detective Oh a sense of your life but
you're gonna have one job at once
perfect other I could transition there
is forensics in interrogation and things
really so you oh my god that's awesome
so yeah so Conan's all about this oh
this is now he's gonna put the towel
telling he's he's a modest person now
he's like don't touch my butt doctor
that's disgusting
so if Newt Gingrich says dr. bill how
does that make you feel so then we also
have the game packs which are smaller
they're cheaper we have one all about
camping which is get the limit that's
the massage parlor and the spa oh my god
amazing and then we have a lot of
different stuff packs which are really
small and those are like 10 bucks
America at least they change prices
based on where you are but there are a
million dollars and then yeah and they
had things like the Wishing Well which
gives you all sorts of crazy wishes it
could kill you it could make your life
better or worse it depends on the mood
of the wishing well and how cheap you
are awesome we generally like to reward
you in the game for being nice to people
and we'd like to sort of punish you for
being a jerk I like that you're you're
you know you people can create anywhere
they want yeah exactly you're teaching
them how to be real human beings outside
of this one with those deaths it's
important that you don't just randomly
die because that's not fun if you have
if you're asking for it well there's
there's the
you're driven deaths and then there's
things that randomly happened to you um
but like if you're really really angry
and you lose your crap
people are gonna you're gonna die you're
just being bad to people yeah but you
know you know the ferry checking things
out we do think that consumes too though
that I think a satellite could just
randomly fall on you and kill you oh my
god so that's one of my biggest fears we
haven't always been kind to people so
they're having a nice dinner here
they're talking you love tanks
apparently to love tanks and so she's
eating a oh I'm hanging out with that
look oh look that's hanging out of the
bar if that's ignoring me like she
always does give me em come time but in
like a [ __ ] block tell me about my game
Titan says I'm gonna need therapy after
I play this game I walk just walked in
the room and responded by saying
seriously and walked out of the room so
she's very embarrassed where a Titan was
just probably staring at naked Conan
which is what was going on what do you
feel he says please no happy ending on
the massage oh my god now we've got now
we've got like a studious also Conan's
time daddy's got some clothes on just
going to bed everybody's tired so you
could see your Sims needs down here and
there's it's hard to see the mouse
because of the TVs yes yes um your Sims
have needs here and so you can find out
how much they have to pee how much fun
they need what's under there what's the
yellow what is the yellow that's the
plum Bob
so that is your quick snapshot at how
they're feeling right now got it because
he's really tired yellows a little bit
it's not it's not terrible it's not good
orange is getting pretty bad red is
terrible red is like horrible things are
about to happen to yourself and so oh oh
no Beth don't do it Beth what have I
told you about trying to sleep are you
thinking about death oh my god so you
right you you you crashed on the couch
so see you're Andy if he always can play
him so we could send Andy do we do we
like Andy do we not like Andy we're
doing because we can say we gets in any
wherever we want right well let's go say
you take a disco nap because Andy likes
the dance
yes what am i oh see let's uh can you
make a sim kill another sim I don't
think so you can't we generally
discourage someone some violence you
could slap each other you have to take
responsibility for killing yeah we it's
it's important to us that we sort of
have a sort of a comical level of
violence yeah um let's do a swan oh yeah
he loves Wanda I'm a majestic majestic
man
so you see everybody starting go to
sleep that's 10:30 at night the bear the
bear trying to can't stop that's out
let's see let's see if the bear can be
impressed by the whishing world you
wanna make a wish I live like a
house-elf what does that mean Bowdoin
live I mean I do in real life like Dobby
what does that even be so I have a
luchador mask apparently when I sleep
biometric ass you ever add cultural
packs like an Asian cultural one for
Japan or China
that's an interesting call that is an
interesting kind of love that I um we
are definitely trying we so we have this
awesome global audience and it's
something that we are trying we're very
aware of that and we're trying to do a
better job with The Sims 4 yes
representing all of our different
audiences around the world that's one of
the reasons we made this European world
is we've never made a world before that
was oh yeah don't worry about this what
the portal the hell that the barriers
just opened in the backyard I wished for
happiness oh and it didn't go so if I'm
nearby tragic dilemma being around
others will cause them sadness but
nearby Sims will find happiness in his
misery oh my god this is this can be so
darn amazing so do you guys have like
this is actually a crazy question but
you have like therapists on staff or
something like have you did you do like
I know it's Sesame Street and they're
making Sesame Street they consulted with
child psychologists to be like you know
what did you ask consulted psychologists
in terms of like relationships and
dynamics and all that stuff we didn't
but we do a lot of research we try to
look up things the sort of weird um
because it's pretty cool because I have
to say like and and not as a joke but
like I love like processing and all that
stuff and just the fact this game is
based on anything like like the
hierarchy of needs or any of that stuff
easy
we do research on so one of the reasons
we came up with the traits is one of the
designers went and looked on like
Craigslist how people describe
themselves cuz games such that people
would be like I'm ten points towards
funny or I'm one point towards serious
and nobody is all in one point serious
yeah yeah we'll say well I'm outgoing
and you know I I love the outdoors
and I'm a great painter and so that's
why we came up with traits and social
dynamics and you could sort of see
almost look at Facebook descriptors on
how people describe is and like you know
it's it's complicated right now or it's
it's hot and cold and so we're trying to
reflect that here and so we try to look
at what's real and serious and try to
put a little bit of source I'm sure of
course but then we make it sort of
ridiculous and fun because ultimately
we're making a game yeah to series it's
more fun we don't want the government to
take over and then actually just cause
the matrix where then we're all just
plugged in and it's a simulated no no no
running your year dangerous territory
exactly so the bear because he's sad um
we want to actually have advantages to
being in different emotions he could do
a sad painting which is what he's doing
right now
oh cool and the fun thing is he can then
give this painting to somebody and if
it's up in their house that painting
will make them sad by the very or okay
so you could go and decorate your your
nemesis is how this is perfect missus
season of society perfect I used to and
when I lived in New York you know you
can have people write things like in
dolphins you know in dolphin text or
whatever you know and I used to have
like right because if you just give me
$30 they'll write anything so I used to
in like douche bag and all just terrible
things so I like to think that I as a as
the bear did that so you're taking a
poop right now oh you know what it's
made a great question
will you guys ever consider face
scanning to get a person's real faces
again or do you kind of like keeping it
a little bit like like we're saying not
keeping it super realistic yeah it's
really tough one of the problems we
found we've experimented with things
like that in the past and one of the
problems is that we're sort of a
stylized game we have to sort of make
this artistic decision and what happens
is the more you combine hyperrealism
with stylized stuff is exerting these
weird Frankenstein's accurate and so we
sort of take that approach of the the
characters and stuff and back to that
cultural question yeah I try to make
sure that we have different facial
archetypes that we
represent different people from around
the world absolutely um so that you
don't you can make you can make some
make just a cartoon version of yourself
no matter what you look yeah yeah
exactly
that's fantastic do you wanna go to
space I love space let's do it oh here's
a great question
shady-ass are some of the pre-made sims
in the game based on staff members who
worked on the game that always
fascinates me yeah or are there hidden
jokes within this game that you guys
think is full of hidden jokes we have
all sorts of for example we have an
expansion coming out where one of the
ideas that came up back on base game
that was just sort of this crazy idea
we're sort of taking a part of it and we
have all sorts of inside jokes in the
text that's all about some of those
things from that past experience from
the people that came up with it yeah we
have a hairstyle that's called the whoa
oh yeah there we go baby we have a
hairstyle that's based on one of our
producers that's on the team all the
names in the game that started the
randomise name yeah all the different
people that work on the game so Oh a
testers and we have QA testers in
Romania and all over the island sir
right yeah all these so you wanna do
Aaron is soaring through the outer
reaches of space when he notices an
insanely bright something glowing below
him if he swings it closer he hears
engines revving he realizes it's an
interstellar racetrack there's a prize
for the winner over these contestants
are no joke let's do it I'm doing the
race I'm in we'll see how this goes now
I can whew now I can fail in space just
like I failed on earth
well maybe there'll be space ladies so
in the first expansion you can actually
if you're a good enough scientist you
can invent a portal and you can go to an
alien world that's awesome because when
oh wait a second wait can we watch the
space race oh yeah
this one's just often so it's off its
base yeah we don't have cameras in space
what are we talking I believe though if
I'm not let me hold on a second I
believe while you're up there we can
listen to a transmission of you in space
if I'm not Oh Cho Chabot says what's the
reason behind the made-up language is
there is there a reason behind it or
it's just kind of very fun to play
around with I have a specific reason or
no I have a fun reason and yeah so the
fun reason is that it's more funny to
sort of hear what they say listening the
Simlish is really funny yes when we have
our voice actors who do voice acting for
like a lot of cartoons and stuff like
that it's amazing
see how much expression and life they
could put in ER absolutely I'm Wally
yeah Wally never said anything but it
you know exactly sure keep it oh keep
pace baby no no push it push it that's
it
so push it like salt-n-pepa's sort of
boring reason is that we're a global
game we need to be in you know I think
somewhere like 20 different languages
right now right we don't want to
translate the text right for thousands
and thousands of percents for 20
different languages
we'd have to charge $2 for the game that
actually read it actually help makes you
less a CAD a game super do well do we
should have kept pace this is great this
is gonna be good Oh No if you're gonna
crash I hope you crash it'll make for a
great show hey Weezer what's up good to
see you
it's actually not oh it's actually not
from Swedish it's a completely made-up
language it's absolute gibberish yes
that race didn't go so well
there's a tiger my first mistake is
putting a tire on a spaceship you're a
little dazed right now totally fine now
wait a second it like I know younger
than everyone else hopefully yeah also a
lot of weight Oh Erin asked you guys
laugh at the glitches especially baby
glitches or get extremely mad that it
got into the full game um you probably
laugh at them but the people who
responds when you play to us we laugh at
them because you have to laugh at those
things and one of the funny things about
the job is that it's amusing to see oh
man there's a party going
however we try to fix them as quickly as
possible you try to have patches of
course of course as we know that it
upsets our fans so we tried your best
but again it's one of things that we try
to we try to take what we can yes yeah
it's the same thing like I was siding
with the Fez day guys and oh my god
like let's just drive us crazy but on
the other hand some of my favorite
moments and fall out or whatever are
crazy glitches so yeah I meant it works
both ways I I had a headache glitch back
on Sims 3 were these Sims fire
extinguisher got stuck to his crotch
sitting there screen yeah it was fire
yeah it's uh that's a great great
painting Rose um we had a glitch the
other day where Sims if you put a
earng next to a toilet they would be
over weird thing really hate the
relative questions sleep your sleep
that's dangerous they could die yeah we
don't recommend that they probably to
drug no how many know how many like
hours or whatever of entertainment did
you guys program into this stuff like
could I sit here and just watch
different shows over no let's see we
have oh my god news nuts so we have all
these different movies oh my god alright
let's see wait watch super kids sins of
the Dead
watch the clumsy sisters The Adventures
of Spacek simulation watch lost dogs
dirty ho moonlight massacre three watch
diamonds are four Sims let's go this is
this can insane this hit came out with a
expansion just a month or two ago this
is a $10 step back it comes with the
huge movie theater
I believe you came with a popcorn
machine Oh Andy has the dance skill oh
now they're awake that the movies
starting
dude look at that booming sounds like
cats movies Mallory says please help me
with my history homework
Kenneth's with some questions will help
you with history these guys don't like
the movie guys dr. Phil's so you've got
this sort of live and let die Louisiana
speedboat scene going on haha
one of my favorite things I have to say
is things with in other games so like
seeing that you could play like the
first Sims on this and like all that
stuff I loved the inception of content
within content you know we've been
around for about 16 years now so we we
like to reference our past and look to
the things conan's up what are some
things that you guys were influenced by
in the in sims 4 like in this iteration
of the same is because you've been
around for so long how do you keep
finding things to add and to improve in
the game well so in sims 3 we did that
we moved up Maslow's hierarchy so this
one we wanted to go even further and
look at the emotional state to sort of
see how Sims process the world around
them how they think about those things
we wanted to make our tools better so we
wanted to make creative sim more
intuitive easier to use so instead of
all these buttons and since I yeah you
gotta grab this is a push and pull our
sort of marketing tagline that our fans
make fun of us for is it's like it's
like mole
clay with you know build we added all
sorts of options to make build simpler
than ever so for example let's say you
don't know anything about building a
house which is true I know nothing you
can go to these already pre-made
asbestos is bad that's all I Nets don't
inhale it's bestest ok you can go to
these pre-made rooms so let's say you
don't know crap about the building a
kitchen yeah can we build like a let's
build look can we build a little guest
house or something yeah sure so you can
go first off we would need let's let's
do the kitchen first so you could start
here with this small kitchen and you
could buy the whole room or you could
just buy individual objects from there
ok so it's sort of like a Pottery Barn
catalog so we can come over here let's
find some space on the lot so you come
here and you plop that down and so now
previously you had to do all sorts of
more complex tools you can just click
and drag the walls and the whole thing
dynamically scales
it'll deduct money from you oh my god
can be like we need a bedroom this one
looks nice so let's do it in pink and
they'll just change all the colors oh my
god so we wanted to make the game easier
to use so much easier to make stuff my
apartment is a mess it's like well we
need doors and let's just call this the
men's room waffle tarts is very subtle
sad painting by the bear yeah you know
what you don't need a lot to convey that
emotion the bear is a terrible artist
you know so we wanted to make everything
simpler or more powerful keep the seller
says Erin we know you're just gonna
light everyone I'm fired let's do this
you can see here you can make this you
can change one foundation oh my god and
it'll stack up I mean it's where you go
down and then you could like goes oh I
like you put it right near the tree this
is perfect the other roots are gonna go
into the the roots are gonna go into the
the septic so there we go just click and
drag and you know 20 30 years I'm gonna
need to replace the whole all the pipes
because all the roots have grown into
the clay that's a mess so you're looking
on the outside and you're like well we
need to have some siding and so let's do
some bricks of course that exposed brick
which is so in use hold this and I'll
sudden you've put those all around the
thing okay so he's asked are you guys
gonna make up another magic pack like in
the first sins what was the magic what
was the magic so in Sims 1 the last pack
we made was called makin magic and it
added me
Edge's and all sorts of crazy spells and
makin with an apostrophe we can you know
know it and it's a fan favorite we've
sort of hinted at it in the past we did
things like supernatural and Sims 3 yeah
I saw it was that it was more fantasy
based it wasn't like it's completely
ríos off the rails completely goof oh
wow that's insolence and something we
like to have left so we have aliens you
could be a ghost right now yeah the fun
thing about the ghost is they reflect
the manner in which they died so if you
died by fire ghosts will be all smoky oh
that's good I think we're home we're
definitely on killing a few people so
you can also search so you could be like
who's I can't spell foods that's a G so
you can spell foosball and you could do
search for items oh wow I'll see the
foosball table you could see the spa if
you'd like to put a spa down do you like
this bum let's put some Halloween candy
in there of course that's why I keep my
candies in my bedroom because when I'm
weeping in bed I just like to eat I'd
like to have a clothes you can add you
know fish bear we can add a bonsai let's
put a couple bonsai trees now I feel
like it's good Fung Shui you can add a
stand-up comedy mic you can add a violin
DJ booth you have a pumpkin card yes yes
definitely definitely yeah I mean yeah
there we go more max that one segment
Nima wants to see some chaos all right
we'll get you go give you some gas go
start a fight Nicolas Cage sim when you
dies we turn into ghosts right so I'm
just enormous right now let's uh let's
have the bear change back that's the
Bears that kind of does look like Mike a
writer Michael Gordon who's the bear so
the bear who is sad oh no chill Vic says
oh my god the search is gonna make life
so much easier that the search is
fantastic it's something forever hey
rifle boat good to see you so we can
come over here and have the bear mock my
outfit which is sort of strange because
he's in a bear suit yeah you know he
thinks he's all high and mighty oh he's
got a pee you can also change the pitch
of your Sims voice is great so you can
make the blood tall Porter's listen to
the roar the sound effects are so good
it's
what are you doing Sam I feel like part
of you is flirting with the bear is that
weird to say there's kind of a sexual
undertone you a little tension that's so
you're so right now you you're here we
go oh my god
it doesn't like a guy diversity let's be
mean and let's uh
I literally own everything seems four
came out with and we'll continue to buy
everything they come out thank you
waiting on a game pack announcement or
update thank you rainbow Deanna thank
you I love you Jim oh man says what new
skills are there since in three so some
of the recent expansion at the DJ Co we
added the dancing skill and the bass
gave me a video game scale program is
she we have mixology which is making
drinks we have cooking guitar violin we
have piano
we have comedy Michigan charisma we have
home I got fitness tune in this is the
master meeting Barrett some kind of skis
if you're just joining us it's a little
weird we're here with Grant Road Nick
and I from we're playing Sims 4 which is
fantastic and they made a whole bunch of
awesome characters for us in this game
so you can just we're gonna keep you in
your sugar I'm trying to make this mean
enough so that we can fight which pack
which pack is the DJ skill that sounds
like a skills and get together it adds a
whole new city get to Dad's
all these like places you can go to
party at night club so you wanna this
looks crazy this is crazy you want
anyone else party actually let's do it
alright so let's get out let's get out
and see some stuff so let's uh travel
let's take the whole Posse we uh
electric we have a Conan sim he's right
there yeah you're gonna see him in just
a second I wouldn't call it weird it's
crazy
you're welcome dorky gal gonna go there
owns yeah you wanna go the ruins are the
haunt this one I like the shiny let's
what do you think Beth Vaughn hot estate
oh yeah the show is great there's ghosts
walking around there's a huge hedge maze
I love all those things I mean I don't
love ghosts cuz they scare me but I love
the idea of ghosts yeah what's that one
of the other cool things we decided with
get together is you can create social
groups and with your social groups eight
oh please call it a crew call it a crew
are squats a little too trendy what
about a squad
okay okay fair enough um yeah like the
Sharks of the Jets so yeah we created
the groups and you can sort of dictate
what your groups do while they're
together so you could say yeah we like
to pick fights with people we like to
whoo-hoo and we like to collect fraud
can we just say keep reciting all the
reservoir dogs' quotes and all of my
friends in high school I'm gonna make it
really sad I'm gonna go add that right
so here we're here at the mansion oh my
god this window here's the hedge maze
this is crazy
commit let's go in the hedge race don't
you worry we're gonna wander the maze
together somebody's gonna pay part of
the sames is the ability to tell your
own stories it leads to hours and hours
of fun well-played Gingras yeah a lot of
the times for our players is they don't
even want to do the careers they want
don't wanna level up the skills they
just want to go 3 with their own stories
they want to make their own home yeah
whoa this is Bernard Bernard he's
thinking right now maybe he died by my
skunk attack dude she's Minzy she's got
a shower for sure that goes you can see
the dirt coming off her I think Minzy
and Bernard I can remember if they hate
each other they like each other
oh yeah else's during this summer I
played for 14 hours straight hashtag no
regrets thank you guys you're dead what
are you fighting about please let it let
sleeping dogs lie
oh she's haunting something I'm right
football no this is on PC not ps4 so one
of the fun things your Sims can do is
that if they're ghosts they can haunt
things most of the bear I hear is really
pass the place eagle said every single
said the club's features pretty cool I
made my own hippie group that to yoga
and curtain Arthur enough of those
people in real life why are you making
them in the city we call that the
Berkeley PAC
oh my god the Berkeley pack so here you
have all these sins are lost and I can
find out what they're doing
yeah do you want actually make a group
you can make this right yeah let's make
a group I wonder and you know what I
want to call them a crew is that okay
with you I know it's I know you know how
about that boo how about this all right
we're gonna make a crew all right how
about Lacroix no no let's call them
Street beat 10,000 come close and spill
ah yeah I'd I'd like to know Bradley's
been overseas be 10,000 doing a picture
icon let's pick our icon oh the
headphones for sure
like all right and then like what's the
description of our crew but like dancing
and dancing in the streets dancing and
sheets you know
hashtag drake life yeah
hashtag drake and then hashtag Drizzy
and there we go
god this is live yes dwb i don't know
how to say your name deep bowl full herb
so what are the things your krob your
you want your people to do together well
so this is gonna change their activity
this is gonna change dance we are all
about dance and we are all about we're
all about dance and we're all about like
talking about stuff because they're like
you know is there a little wait can we
use science objects too though Oh real
quick yeah oh there's gonna be a sweet
screw over oh man I got it I got to
write this down because then I want my
real crew in my real life to do this to
you what else do we do I think you know
yeah we're makers or mayhem and their
avatars objects weren't people mmm okay
yeah I'll either one your you pick you
pick sabotage all right sabotage cuz you
know we'd like to cause mischief you
know club activities hmm oh wait do you
be mean you could fight other people
what I mean though we're more just likes
to argue money or money yeah we're
pretty funny we're funny yeah oh that's
actually a fun one see it would be funny
to everyone
oh just people within your club just
people of your age oh yeah just people
of our age so that would be young adults
yeah let's do not know adults everybody
can we do can we do more than one Oh
baby there we go you there everybody
don'ts yeah kids do screw dolls and so
you can also pick all these different
people into your crew all right yeah
let's yeah we don't want we remembe I
will do that yeah we're on it we ran out
of room now for that no that's good
that's good so the other fun thing is
you could choose who can actually be in
the club or not interest on Oh arty
music that's where dance is of course
perfect yeah that's important to me I
want to make sure we should dance one
more
Oh Beth what's our last one spa
activities
I don't know I don't miss any music I'm
so lame though cuz you know it's like we
don't even drinking our drinks grilled
cheese yeah well thank you filled cheese
where's grilled cheese crew these guys
are hilarious thank you so are you so
now we've created that Club and the bear
is the head of the club and so now over
time yes Snoop Dogg is in the house
tonight he's on the show and so you can
see the people with the beats over their
head dude yes cute dog oh this is great
oh wait oh I see so now okay so so
that's part so he's the head of the
group which way as that crown was head
and so he can rally the whole group
while they're hanging out together
they're gonna do all the things that
they're supposed to be doing so so
they're gonna try to dance and they're
gonna basically just do the things so
what's really funny as players can
change the spectively the autonomy and
behaviors of their sims you meet all
sorts of rivalries between different
grill my god you get a battling huge a
month using capital you can see you Oh
show up to this bar that like whenever
each other life that's how do you guys
feel about using mods and costume
contents so custom I guess you think
custom yeah so uh we officially don't
use them but wait can I hit on this
ghost though real quick
absolutely you wanna see if you have a
better chance with her yeah yeah I know
she's undead but I feel really funny or
rude oh let's go in funny let's go in
funny Oh take it a chance though no no I
think this is down as I do in real life
she's in she's oh but she's also dead
your tents also because you're startled
by a ghost
so okay wait dude go back hey what's up
what am i banana peel open with banana
peel bro oh now I'm trying to talk about
art so what do you do next monkey tell
joke about monkeys all right here we go
Hey Oh map totally getting cock-blocked
you look
No someone said that girl is so
transparent yeah see right through me I
tell funny story tell funny story let's
do that oh man this guy is totally this
look at his body language he's putting
me down Missy walks away modified ghost
voice she says she's got a pretty good
figure for a ghost
I'm gonna be honest not bad now I'm
talking about llamas was happy with me
dude if you stop with a banana peel
thing it's all you've got
how do I know if she's liking me no not
no my god no oh don't are you sure you
work about child children's toys how do
I know if she likes me or not so you see
these little green things about the head
that keep popping up this is where your
relationship is going you just start it
out so you're only acquaintances so you
keep telling jokes
let's go robot invasion let's just go
full nerd at this point can we just get
let's go robot invasion and see the
reason you have that is because you are
a nerd this is not gonna go well prove
my manhood kit this month snuggle I'm
not into that
a romantic tale with Achilles and he's
creepy why the bushes did you know vent
complain any problems doing fresh I
don't know what do I do guys Beth what
should I do
I think I'm losing her you might need to
move away from the jokes now I don't
want to be the friend zone no no no no
my friend letter you can go straight for
it you can go for the romance romance
pickup line
oh that's compliment or appearance
that's that's sort of platonic there we
go I think I'm like doing something
about her fun bags yeah I think you're
raising the roof oh my god don't talk
about a galaxy Berkeley octopus is gonna
know now Kyle's gonna come in this is
always what happens true story he's
embarrassed
Koni you would encounter Conan and
notice her mood is reflected in her
ghost
so she's embarrassed so she's yellow
yeah just like in real life and now
she's screwing with you Oh oh man this
is exactly how it goes down I counted
seeing it all now Conan's gonna come no
blur it's cool you reduced this video
game thing
nice is your friend you should go away
and when I do this thing he's a cool guy
he's a cool dude but she disappears
she's actually wanting this a light
fixture not very ambitious goes oh you
could praise the leader of Street be all
right there we go
sucking up to Ernesto the worst wingman
ever
hey oh wait she's back now Conan all
right you see if Conan can talk to her
yeah yeah see if Tony can hit on her
back in this way so isn't that just
typical women ghosts
wait trusting up against evergreen tree
life send a lone you know sorry grant I
have no chance now frost my finger
Gladys he seems getting some love Cubs
fan since 4 on Xbox one ps4 soon we're
not sure we don't know right we don't
right now it's only on the PC that's all
with the PC Lisa's be available in the
gallery uh you know we can look into
there yeah we can look into it there's
that gallery thing I told you about
which is how we can upload all sorts of
Sims and yes so earlier you guys were
asking about online it's a single-player
experience because yeah troll however
you could share your experiences and so
you can upload your house and then Erin
can play it and then yeah a week later
you can find out how paths diverged and
then I could send Beth photos of the
avatar she's made as I've murdered
murdered them in the murder pool when I
when I was in Grand Theft Auto I was a
Grand Theft Auto five I'm 25% of all the
joggers slash personal trainers so when
that game came out all my friends sent
me photos of them like just dead bodies
so they're like I found you I found you
that's like you guys whoa all the
toilets are broken on this lot waffle
turd says the ghost took going to the
light a little too little
oh you guys are on fire today it's on
fire in PR quality puns exactly let's
cause a little chaos so these are just
people staying at this place they're
just no these are just neighbors so
these
his neighbors the wood is full of rabies
we had control we didn't make these
people they're just here they're just
here they're just chilling they're on
vacation
coated straight and you notice these
guys belong to others so they belong to
good timers in the spin that you hate
create Spin Master so if you wanted you
get actually down there leaving this
having an unpleasant conversation so
mischief oh [ __ ] I forgot the thing that
I put in Conan's coat yes Conan just did
some Conan just did a little dance so
John has a voodoo doll whoa what do you
mean
so he's gonna bind it to me so anything
he does the video it's gonna be done to
me oh right so he probably wishes he had
this got about the voodoo doll I also
forgot about the cow plant I meant to do
that earlier I didn't that's okay that's
okay so now Conan's got his blade you
doll your mama is a llama complete with
a tape
oh now going away he doesn't need ya in
real life he doesn't mean I am his
voodoo voodoo do you want to tickle him
poke him Wow let's poke him all right
it's a feat that does I see your phone
and dancing see you you're in pain now
because of the booty ah let's see if I
can change his personality now I can be
rude to people yes sometimes some of the
chaos takes a little bit of time that
makes that difficult in a live demo
let's show some people some of the other
custom content they can get cool
I'm actually not hooked up online but we
got you actually I come on your wife I
believe so peas we're doing great good
to see you oh oh no no no forget it you
don't get to see it guys sorry sorry
sorry but we all right let's cause some
chaos though let's get a little crazy oh
let's see so Conan where's the bear the
bear hates everyone the bear hates it
when we hate the bear we hate the bear
he hates us so let's come over here and
get in a fight with Conan bear why are
you sleeping oh he peed his pants
perfect fix glad to see you like you
could join us better late than never
better late than never
where are you bear man how the Bears
like just an emotional roller coaster
and see nobody can pee because the
toilet broken so sons are peeing their
pants
so Andy Richter just peed himself he's
all stinky oh my god the bear all see
this wise thing as long as the bear is
just so damn sad dude he's the leader of
street big 10,000 what do you have to be
sad about bear you already painted a sad
painting there's a hot dog hold on hold
on
here comes Beth Beth you're gonna cheer
up the bear it's gonna be awesome this
is always sort of a weird live broadcast
because I don't really know what the
sins are gonna do I don't know where
they're I know that's great it's just
like life great it's like life that's
it's perfect like the best and worst
parts of parenting and yeah I think this
should be honestly very good for me to
learn how to be to babysit my nephew you
know cuz it doesn't matter if these guys
dive if my nephew gets killed my
sister's gonna be really upset you sort
of get that that this youth
this is a good ah you know what I'm
gonna go out on a limb against my PR
handlers wishes and say yes so he said
the bear and the hot dog is the next big
Pixar movie which by the way that's a he
needs to maybe see a doctor if it's
great perfect dude the scuffle so he's
gonna win I feel like the bear because
it's hard to punch through that suit
it's pretty thick
come on cocky yeah but then he a Conan
does work out all the time so that's
right yeah the commentary so dope I know
I do love when they talk to each other
it's awesome rest of the bear he's
confident because he defeated a bear in
a fight cuz so the thing is that the
other Sims don't know that that guy's
not a human they think it's a bear got
it because it's such a it's such a
convincing bear costume yes hot dog stop
them that's a bad jujitsu and the ghost
haunted the broken toilets what am i
doing over there I'm just sitting oh
you're tired so we haven't really been
taking care of our sims needs and so
they're all just basically getting quick
naps here and there oh I see so I'm just
kind of like a little disco nap like
actually let's go
can we go put me in the death dungeon
yes let's do it
yes let's go let's go back to the house
we made let's do that this is actually a
did I give you guys guys this is actual
footage Conan Conan actually fought a
bear it was actually some good yeah we
got some really good fan er there was a
thing a couple years ago whereas Conan
how did that even start coated versus
the bear so he's a fan art that was so
great of Conan and a bear Conan Barretts
in Conan barely survived well played
guys man the chat is on fire today by a
player I mean we go yeah you guys are
burning to death do this fire exactly
exactly
ninja muffin what you did something
that's true the best comment today
somebody said the Conibear fight
reminds me the revs new pair that's like
the cartoon person there's there's an
Oscar Leo to prepare for the rabbinate
did play The Sims 4 and he won an Oscar
so guys exactly method acting fight a
man you all right so now we're back home
home sweet home bets you look miserable
let's feed everybody give these guys you
know Street be 10,000 can't get down
with the sweet jams overall hunger
that's gone and make a meal frog
yeah although I don't know about cone
it's cookie skills but let's do it so we
can pick ask about height change for
this Sims okay can you do hot tall and
short Sam's or no they're all kind of
the same you're all the same well you
can go you can go why exactly because
it's so sad to see oh oh we speeded up
time cuz it's so sad to see Sims not
being able to reach a shelf PT mode you
said why is there hot dog guy Pete hot
dog is actually a girl and the girl is
Beth and she's a hot side because at my
birthday party two years ago I'd like to
give people presents on my birthday and
Beth got my hot dog costume do you want
to put up a picture or am I gonna put up
the picture I think it's on my Instagram
of Beth and the hot dog see it was also
children's outfit so it didn't quite fit
either of us so Conan's quite skilled
well done he made that looks like bacon
beans pork and beans baby call everyone
to the meal we'll get everyone here do
you want an Oscar play the sims 4 you
heard it here first
why dr. Phil because I don't know dr.
Phil why not why not why not friend of
the show do we answer your question with
the question hey look dr. Phil gets the
dishes oh they came to your apartment
over here Oh perfect
you mean my yeah exactly my bachelor pad
so we can have a hot dog as Yoda depends
just kind of cook in real life ooh good
question I don't know if he could Sarah
I mean you know I don't know he's rich
and famous so he probably doesn't why
would you why would you why would you
bother with it I think enough are you
guys gonna add laundry in The Sims I
would love the addition of doing laundry
it sounds gonna be a laundry deal this
is something we talk about and think
about but it's also it's um it's hard to
make really fun and interesting well
sure I I can only imagine like you guys
must get requested you because people
want this Mike they weigh everything
Sims is life so it was really tough to
do well I'm sure it's tough to do
appropriately and get everything
beastmode what up yourself good to see
you Conan is committed you guys admitted
to be a terrible coat that's pretty good
Koni cooks the blood of his enemies does
it need to be cooked I feel like that's
better raw lucky did killing her there
you go so now everybody's eating loose
flirty work this is a flirty sculpture
which means that it can make a flirty
environment flirty is one of the
emotions that we have sure like the sad
painting with the bear exactly so you
can make people a little bit more flirty
oh I love it you can actually as the DJ
you can change people's emotions all
around you with your music some guru
sees that there should be a laundry
sorting minigame just like if that's the
sin of like shaving minigame guys you
can do mini game for anything VR leg
shaving motion cantaloupe Pro potato
prepped here from Norway's huge hot hot
dog origins the next can we put Beth
into the dungeon death dungeon I want to
see her just you know what this is karma
this is an honor for all the students
even exactly so we're gonna stop feeding
her so wait so what do we have
let's look in the death dungeon so we've
got a bed a toilet but no way out no way
in really and I notice there is a
skeleton and also on the other side
there is this to monitor this is this
one we're a nuclear strike this is
scientific equipment for experimenting
and creating things this is for me I'm
at work right now
obviously the obstinate scientist is a
cheat real quick and we're just gonna
teleport her down here
brother time what do you mean laundry is
loads of fun
leave immediately Sweden also says hello
hello Hank oh hello that's right so we
can send Conan down here up rifle ball
turns Swale in my god rifle boats from
swin I said swindlin I'm in Finland you
know swim London with the swinish yes
this is the 50 shades dungeon this is
yeah this is the 50 shades expansion
pack see I put you in here now where I
belong behind bars Oh Beth please good
lord he's embarrassed because he broke
privacy in the prison right now which
isn't really a great a new game to make
play lose his mind I am hot dog and
apparently Conan only pees in the bushes
just like real he's doing his peepee
dance as good as peepee that's the
bushes are one of our most flexible new
objects you can sleep in them you can
use really assuming you can also woohoo
in them what's what do you mean woohoo
when a sim in a sim love each other very
much
say no more say no more you can do it in
the observer the rocket what bad did hot
dog do I don't know Beth you want to
explain your actions while you're in the
death dungeon yeah what did you do it's
what you didn't do it really I just love
to kill and this is my retribution
exactly this is karma this is terrible
terrible karma are so bored hello
Jessica from Denmark we're just gonna
leave you there Oh see you're sleeping
please simply saying a dlc bush dlc the
bush egg woohoo the bushes and get
together which is the second expansion
pack that came out in December that's
awesome I love it I would just you know
what I think in my bachelor pad I would
just have all bushes
you know that's all you need here's Andy
cleaning himself up and he's also got
the same tattoo Oh Conan has Lou
copycat I know Oh see I came home from
work and I made us 400 bucks
way to go dude you're the only one
pulling the weight and the dance crews
there you call me fat Street beat ten
thousand yeah that's gonna sum I'm a
scientist a hot dog that kills yes
Little Miss Carla you can woohoo in the
bushes and I love the Emotiv this is how
it's been you know what now there will
be the lifeless eyes they've made their
lifeless no matter waiting up to that
just like you can you can have the bear
try to put the Moose on coming can we
now can we destroy any of this house oh
can we do anything bad to the house yes
so let's do it fire can occur let's let
you know what everyone is sleeping
there's no better time to start a fire
that's what I say I'm just no better
time because we're almost out of time so
I feel like we need to see this kind of
flames where's the fire whoo-hoo hashtag
woohoo it's Erin and Cohen no that's a
terrible hashtag where's the fire here
we go debug start fire so woah you start
the fire wait oh my god normally this
happens from Sims who die by fire or
Sims who are bad at cooking oh my God
look at this everybody Oh
bears bears putting it out no bear start
another fire somewhere don't worry I
cancelled it no one knows what to do oh
no coating what are you doing
Cullens a bit of a coward oh my god two
fighters this is crazy
so we have all sorts of fighters did you
will the fire grow the fire will grow
but it needs to catch onto objects I'm
doing a video I see let's let the couch
on fire I feel like couch is always
great yeah masturbating bear is putting
out the fire rose oh the bear caught on
fire Oh No
Oh bear oh my god Oh No Oh bear it looks
like a dig it's party broke out this is
finally how we getting out starting to
spread Oh
crazy what guys what are you doing way
outside so it's a slant Cydia sleep
you're asleep I'm tired
well done now I know not to who to go to
it not to go to in a bun right and you
made the bonsai all killed it damn it
maybe so yeah this was all look they
look the the couch is all charred
already so and if we don't know buddies
hoping the baby we don't take care of
the bear this is a bear must lives this
Kip the snuggler Musti Musti I don't
think so
dinner's served we're having big smoky
the vs. no oh no really he's really
taking a long time with a bear to burn
up once so we have to try to set up fire
fires like the big bad of the game oh
you have to make it such that it doesn't
spread too quickly or else I can ruin
everything
something will be destroyed yeah and it
also takes some time to put together you
can also you can put a fire alarm here
and it'll put it out you can make on of
an anti fire system but we apparently
invest everything but that you just the
Bears so did you come back as a bear
ghosts that can take some time but it's
possible
where's death this is why at Smokey the
Bear hated fire oh there's the Grim
Reaper oh my God look at this this is
crazy
I've come for you bear whoa is he
working on it due to plead for Ernesto
hmm what does that mean like see you
tried to bring him back
yeah yes look plea for him yeah see if
you Ares Evan gets over here okay so the
problem is there's still so many fires
that everyone's afraid so I'm not sure
this is gonna happen no where are you
I'm just like my guys I don't get to see
the sweet fire yeah you lol bear goes so
we barely knew is death just like
looking on his eye or her iPad to see
what's going on yeah of course that's
just playing Angry Bird he's a droid guy
yeah he's a no comment that was a Oh
guys that was a
is lee death that's a good one so now we
have an intern yeah now we have an urn
not an intern oh my god
oh wait death is like freaking out about
the fire - you're dead why are you
freaking out about the fire look sims
don't always make the most can you light
the Grim Reaper on fire someone's asking
there's a chance you might catch on fire
but usually he should bears Night's
Watch is ended only you could prevent
sim fires so Jeff he might hang around
for a little bit you get to oh my god
can we get death into our crew probably
not yeah our dance crew I bet death is a
pretty good dancer he barely knew how to
get rid of the fire guys that was you
can't use the same word came the great
innovation Prez it was great I'll see we
got a $2,800 and juice box says now have
an interval now we know what grant
thinks in the end just ashes I hate the
interns okay oh good question can you
befriend the Grim Reaper oh my god we're
starting a preposterous rumor oh this is
great he's very playful I did death has
a lot of good gossip you know he knows
all about things yeah definitely death I
bet has seen some stuff and he's buying
the bear way to heaven
okay that's at least Oh death has some
killer moves oh my god guys unbelievable
on fire today like the sins I got fire
doctor feels just like well there's a
fire why the heck is he your apparently
you sleep in a llama man costume yeah
what's the problem of that what's the
problem
sorry problem I sleep in a lot of man
costume what's the problem and any
richter is your health costume I'll just
like to be like the Dreamtime cosplay
there's still a fire somewhere hold on
where's that fire I think they put it
out oh no there's a little fire
somewhere checking it out
oh it's out its out see now I can
replace all these things oh that's great
so we wanted to be a problem but not too
of course there he said why am i said oh
that's cuz her nesto died and I loved
her Oh from witnessing death of loved
one the death of a loved one affects
those close to them Sims can mourn in a
tombstone to feel more at peace oh my
god that's awesome so for the next two
days the sim will oh you know what Danny
asked can you woohoo death or is it too
dark for the Sims I don't know you know
we don't know if death has parts that
you could get along with I don't want to
get to you don't here yeah exactly I
mean it seems like death would be there
but some pretty heavy stuff
so I honestly can't remember if we can
or cannot will who at death I know we
have lots of social options but I know a
lot of crazy stuff happens and I know
there's a lot of things with death that
sometimes are sort of like should we let
that happen should we now let that
happen right I hope you have some killer
insurance can you dance with death yeah
I think you can guys we were just
hanging with with the Big D telling some
stories you know the big day oh sorry
the dirty D just dead Conan's over here
on the balcony like an evil maniac
playing with his this is what he does
that's what he does right before it goes
up to the model like just stabs blade
might be killer in bed oh god you guys
this is we have to shut down this chat
the terrible jokes for puns kids don't
clap for me that was bad you know you're
right sorry guys we're almost done for
today so get your questions about Sims 4
in now a shaker idea or assumes are
completely at this point let's do it oh
you're in the copyright and like
companies and if you ever like would add
real products oh that's a good question
Kida great so we've done in the past
it's a matter of whether it's a the
right fit for our game and whether it's
the right fit for our fans we don't want
to just spam stuff in the game we want
to make sure that it's all really cool
that it'll make the game more fun the
universe yeah and so it's something that
we do very carefully and so I don't I
don't recall if we have any in Sims 4
right now I don't think we do and it's
just a matter of finding the right
partnerships oh my god
Steph Arena says yes you can marry the
Grim Reaper see I knew somebody there
you go it's one things I've been working
on the game for so long and there's so
many
different parts of it that I have to
remember that I can't keep track of what
I can always Andy is and eating here the
bonsai tree because we know what
happened to kill that other yeah Andy
what the hell man he's a terrible bonsai
and I thought see all the sins are at
the point where they all have to
desperately sleep and you too might die
in the dungeon country wants to know
will there be a medieval dlc any idea
there's all sorts of discarded petitions
start a petition we need so far you're
behind the sorting laundry and leg
shaving yes leg shaving is top leg
shaving is top priority
then laundry sorting men maids a hairy
problem to solve but then oh this game
needs a Deadpool costume interesting I'd
be fun that would be fun
coming rated-r we got to be careful yeah
exactly that ESRB might be like exactly
perfect there's different shapes based
on the emotions that they have I love
that
so I there's all these like funny low
expressions of who your sims are and
what interests them yes I love your
slippers those are pretty tight they're
pretty nice who wears their slippers to
bed dude take off your slippers that
you're dirtying up the bed right rody ik
where's the slippers dude that's what my
mom told me you never go to save your
[ __ ] chemicals may be a bad
circulation yeah really about that got
those old man well guys I think that's
gonna do it for today thank you all for
joining us thank you to grant Thank You
Sims for even the puns of course thank
you guys amazing puns you're on fire and
go get Sims for now it's out now Yes Man
two packs with expansion packs you're
playing today get together the get to
work you could try the create a sim demo
for free on origin there we go go and
get the crazy set up see if you like it
oh absolutely you can woohoo in the
bushes if you get to get together pack
yeah you get to get together which is
what I'll be doing absolutely because
you know woohoo gonna push this is a
bucket list start a bucket list cited
for me but guys thank you for joining us
we will see you next week bucket the
sims 4 is thank you to grant and see you
next week
you